non seulement je compte sur vous je
pouvais compter sur moi mais combien si
je crois que tous nos concitoyens compte
compte sur vous et savent reconnaître
votre professionnalisme
voilà la qualité des soins sont apportés
par le système français merci à vous
pour sa professeure alors comment vous
voyez les choses
oui un peu alors c'est la réponse tout à
l'heure je pense que il va y avoir une
situation à peu à l'italienne c'est à
dire qu'en fait là on a quand même des
chaînes de transmission autochtone
c'est-à-dire les cas français notamment
le patient est décédé hier ici à la
pitié plus le kaki hospitalisé un lien
ces deux patients qui n'ont pas de liens
avec la chine
donc ça traduit le fait est une chaîne
de contenus des chaînes de transmission
autochtone en france et donc ça veut
dire que le virus circule déjà parmi
nous donc c'est ça la vérité qu'il faut
malheureusement avoir à annoncer le
virus les personnes qui sont décédées
vous me disiez ne sont pas décédées
directement du viril ans alors allez-y
il se trouve qu'effectivement les deux
personnes qui sont décédées en france
sont des personnes qui soient avait une
comorbidité par exemple comme le patient
chinois était décédée à bichat soit sont
décédés d'une autre pathologie
même s'ils étaient affectés mais lâché 1
que j'ai laissé parler de ça parce que
c'est quand même le chef de service de
la réanimation dans lequel le patient
est décédé pour je préférerais que ce
soit lui qui en parle plutôt points mais
je pense qu'il est il faut y est très
important en italie les patients qui
décèdent
c'est beaucoup de pression qui sont âgés
environ des comorbidités des cancers les
choses comme ça donc si vous voulez moi
je vois un peu cette infection comme la
grippe même jeu semaine je sais que
c'est pas le virus de la grippe c'est
clair mais je vois ça un peu comme le
virus comme la grippe
c'est à dire c'est une maladie qui
touche des personnes fragiles des
personnes avec des comorbidités des
personnes âgées
même si évidemment il peut y avoir des
patients jeunes qu'ils soient également
touchés
voilà un presse de problème ça va être
l'effet nombre à gérer comme ça vous
avez expliqué tout à l'heure c'est à
dire que même si la gravité beaucoup
plus faible que ce qu'on croyait parce
que probablement talent et beaucoup
france 3 y est probablement que ça se
transmet beaucoup mieux que ce qu'on
pensait ces deux réalités qu'on constate
actuellement les a précédés paiement
c'est à dire que si vous avez même si
c'est 0 2 0 1 % de mortalité
je dis n'importe quoi il m'est donc
c'est ça c'est probablement un peu plus
élevé mais bon c'est difficile à savoir
on n'a pas un vent dénominateur au jour
d'aujourd'hui
donc la réalité qu'il faut dire c'est
qu'on sait pas parce qu'on nous n'avons
pas de bons dénominateur c'est à dire
nous ne savons pas combien de personnes
sont affectées et combien parmi ces
personnes infectées ont bien resta
symptomatique probablement beaucoup
combien font des petits symptômes un peu
plus ils combien font dessinent des
maladies graves beaucoup beaucoup moins
mais on ne connaît pas le pourcentage
exact
donc c'est un vrai problème mais mettons
que ce pourcentage est de 0 1%
si vous on a 1000 personnes le système
n'aura aucun problème pour prendre en
charge
mais si c'est un million de personnes ou
10 millions de personnes dans un espace
très réduit de temps voilà on va avoir
de grosses difficultés avec la logique
chez un des enjeux c'est de ralentir au
maximum
oui